so I want you to make a list today but
before I tell you what that list is I
got a simple question I want to ask you
who do you think can have more of an
impact on your life let's just say you
have the best mentor in the world that
you get to choose anybody pick them Pat
I'd love to have you as a mentor maybe
Tony maybe Ilan pick whoever you think
is the best mentor for you and imagine
if you have this person in your life and
simultaneously you have five negative
people in your life okay so one
incredible mentor and five absolutely
negative people in your life who do you
think wins I'm being serious
who do you think wins do you think even
with those five negative people in your
life in this one incredible mentor do
you think you're still gonna end up
winning who's more powerful you see
there's this whole notion that people
think if I had this incredible mentor
Papp I'm gonna kill it in life even with
the five negative people in my life it's
not how it works see it doesn't work
that way
those five and negative people have way
more influence on your life
than that one incredible mentor and
here's why think about these people that
are super successful how many people
think have worked with them directly
think about it how many people think
Elon is touched how many people think
Steve touched Gates is touched
Tony's touched how many people think
they've touched how come not all of them
became successful they're incredible
mentors aren't they why is that she
because even the most ridiculous mentor
in the world can't stop those five
negative people that steal all the
dreams from your mind and from your
heart they don't have that kind of
influence so that negative cousin of
yours that calls you [ __ ] and all the
time you got to stop picking up his
calls that friend of yours that's always
spreading gossip to you about
everybody's personal life you got to
stop picking up her calls that best
friend of yours from high school who
thinks rich people are greedy and they
suck
sucking all your dreams out of you and
you don't even know it you know what
it's like here's what it's like a
negative person is like a virus you
never know where you got the flu from
you never know where you got the cold
from but you do have the cold and you do
have the flu and unless if you figure
out who that person is you're shaking
hands with day one like this and then
she shook your hand or he shook your
hand you'll never know where that virus
comes from today in your life there are
a handful of people that are ruined you
from winning big before you become a
millionaire first must cut your expenses
you don't need a $200 a month budget on
cigarettes $400 a month on coffee you
probably have a thousand dollars of
wasted money you spend on every month
that you get to stop wasting money on
that's expenses and you probably have a
handful of friends cousins relatives
that you can't stop picking up their
calls that you must stop picking up
their calls and so the list is five
people in your life that you know who
they are and you're afraid of speaking
to them stop speaking to them because
their friends their relatives make a
list and stop talking to them see what
happens to your life I know it's hard to
do very few will do it but that's why
only few people end up making a big in
life and then if you do that maybe very
soon an incredible mentor will show up
into your life and is willing to pour
into you because you finally I decided
to cut your expenses I hope you do that
oh and by the way if you haven't
subscribed yet please subscribe to the
channel love you have a great week